hello and welcome in this video
i explain to you what logistic
regression is
and how you can calculate it online and
we get started right now
in the previous videos we talked about
linear regression
in the linear regression the dependent
variable is metric
for example salary or body hate
whenever you want to use a categorical
variable
as your dependent variable you must use
a logistic regression
so an example could be that you want to
predict if an
employee has a risk of getting a burn
out or not so your dependent variable
would be
burnout risk yes or no
in order to predict your dependent
variable burnout risk
you could use the educational attainment
of the person
the weekly working hours and the age of
the employee
so the question now is what is a
logistic regression
a logistic regression is a special case
of regression analysis
and it is calculated whenever the
dependent variable
is nominally or ordinarily scaled
let's look at some examples first we
have a business example
the business example could be that for
an online retailer
you need to predict which product a
particular customer
is most likely to buy in order to do
this
you receive a data set with past
visitors
and their purchases from the online
retailer
a second example is a medical one
you want to investigate whether a person
is at risk of a certain disease or not
for this purpose you receive a data set
with deceased and non-deceased
people as well as other medical
parameters
the third example is a political example
your question could be would a person
vote for
party a if there were elections next
weekend
all of these examples have in common
that in each case
the dependent variable has the
characteristics
yes or no
let's take a deeper look in what
logistic regression is
first it is important to know that
dichotomous variables
with 0 and 1 or yes or no
can be predicted by using a logistic
regression
in a logistic regression the probability
of occurrence of characteristic one
which is the characteristic present or
yes
is estimated let's look at an example
in the field of medicine here a common
goal is
to find out which variables have an
impact
on a disease in this case
zero could stand for not deceased
and one would be deceased and the
influence of
age gender smoking status
and behaviors on the particular disease
could be examined so here we can see
this example
in a graph on the left side we see the
independent variables
age gender and smoking status
and on the right side we have our
dependent variable
which is disease yes or no and we want
to use
our independent variables in order to
predict
whether a person gets a disease or
doesn't get the disease so the question
now is
why can we not just use a linear
regression
a linear regression would just draw a
straight line
through the data points the graph shows
that values between plus and minus
infinity can occur the goal
of logistic regression is to estimate
the probability of occurrence
not the value of the variable itself
the range of values for the prediction
is restricted
to the range between 0 and 1.
since only values between 0 and
1 are possible the logistic function f
is used so therefore i will show you
what the logistic function is the
logistic model
is based on the logistic function the
important thing
about the logistic function is that only
values between
0 and 1 are possible so if we have
plus infinity the logistic function
would result in
1 and if we have minus infinity
the logistic function would result in 0.
this is the equation for the logistic
function
so the logistic function is 1 divided by
1 plus e to the power of
minus set and for set we insert
the equation of the linear regression
so this is the final equation for the
logistic regression
now the task is to determine the
coefficients b1
up to bk and a of course this is done
by the statistical software you don't
have to do it yourself
and i will show you now how you can
easily do it online
in order to do this please visit
datadeb.net
and click on the statistics calculator
if you want to use your own data just
click on
clear table i will use the example data
now
so we want to perform a regression
that's why
we open the tab regression on the left
side
you can choose your dependent variable
if you want to perform a logistic
regression
you have to choose a categorical
variable
this could be gender place of residence
company academic degree on the right
side you can choose your independent
variables
once you chose your variables the
results of the logistic regression
will automatically appear here below
thanks for watching and bye
you